last time we talked about some cases
where you'd want to use branches for
your solo projects you might also want
to use branches to keep things organized
when working with others if you and your
collaborators all make changes on the
same branch you can't easily work on
separate features simultaneously a
common workflow for people working on
projects together includes making a new
branch for every feature or bug fix this
way if multiple people are working on
changes at the same time they can each
check out their branch to continue work
after taking a break without worrying
about things changing out from under
them then once a feature or bug fix is
complete the author can either update
master to also point to the tip of the
new branch or if there have been changes
to master in the meantime combine it
with the current master using gets merge
feature will talk about merging in
detail later I've actually been working
on our new feature for the asteroids
game that adds a new game mechanic in
addition to getting points for
destroying asteroids and spaceships you
can also collect coins by touching them
with your ship this has a new challenge
since there are now some things that you
want to hit and others that you want to
avoid I'm finally ready to share this
branch with Caroline so I tell her that
she can check out the branch and play
test it so that I can get some feedback
before adding it into the main branch
thanks now Sarah told me that her branch
is named coins so I'll check it out
using git checkout coins now I get this
message saying that branch coins is set
up to track remote branch coins from
origin whoa that's a few words you
haven't heard before the fact that it's
a remote branch means that I didn't
create it myself instead Sarah created
it and so I'm looking at her branch
you'll learn more about remotes in
lesson 3 but for now once I've checked
out the branch it behaves just like the
branches that I created myself now I'll
open the index.html file and try the
game out now this is a coin right here
that Sarah added and when I run into it
then my score goes up cool now you might
be wondering why Sarah's version of the
game doesn't have color that's because
Sarah started working on this branch
before color was added to master to see
this I'll do a git log so I can see that
these recent commits are all by Sarah if
I scroll down to get to the most recent
commit that wasn't from Sarah I see that
it's this one where I reverted
the controls back from my experiment in
Lesson one that's because this was the
latest commit on master at the time when
Sarah checked out her branch by contrast
if I check out master and run git log
there I can see many newer commits that
are more recent than the commit that
Sarah started working on the color
commit is right here it can also help
you visualize the branch structure via
the command git log - - graph I'll also
add the flag - - one-line to make the
output shorter and easier to see and
I'll need to tell git which branches I
want to visualize so I'd like to see
master and coins at this point these
commits existed before the coins branch
was created these are commits that Sarah
added to the coins branch and these are
commits that were added to master after
the coins branch was created now that
you've seen what commits are in each
branch grab a pencil and paper and draw
a diagram of the commit history in the
asteroids repository including the
easy-mode master and coins branches you
don't have to include all the old
commits just however many of the recent
commits you think will be informative
when you're finished - check this box if
you're having trouble try using git log
to see what commits are on each branch
and make sure you watch the solution
video to compare your diagram to Sarah's